on facture par la plage et on se
retrouve via leur diplôme et une team et
les résultats on va les voir ensemble
moi ça me plaît ce gérant du lieu où
elle en est où la gestation d'une petit
piaf
ah bin là on est très très proche de
l'accouchement
on a terminé le tournage début octobre
on est reparti en métropole pour faire
le montage image tout ça et monte à son
et puis là on vend des jeunes et on a la
chance d'être obligé de revenir pour
faire les tous les post synchronisation
tout ce qu'on n'a pas pu bien
enregistrées pour des raisons de jeu
devant de mer tout ça pour faire la
finition de soins comme j'ai beaucoup
d'acteurs ici en dehors des trois
acteurs enfants que son solde
sakari et et on est là il ya quand même
moment une quinzaine d'acteurs
sont des roches membres ici et donc on a
fait toutes ces petites rustine des
petites choses comme ça pour que le film
soit parfait et puis on va le montrer
aussi aux gens qui nous ont aidé ici la
commission du film qu'elle n'a été
vraiment épatante et moi je veux dire
c'est eu un tournage extraordinaires ici
quoi la tournée trois mois j'étais venu
en repérage
je crois que je vais demander la
nationalité polonaise mais tu rigoles ou
quoi
on est intime et les résultats on va les
voir ensemble toi tu es là chef et
rappelle donc un peu plus d'autorité
là on est en train de me montrer mixer
les paroles et la synchro chez mc
productions cnbc prod et c'est vraiment
un grand un très bon matériel
on a des techniciens beaucoup de
techniciens
d'ici on a eu beaucoup d'acteurs va
vraiment c'est une terre c'est hollywood
sur son réunion gers est vraiment
épatant je veux dire j'ai fait j'ai
passées ici re des meilleurs tournage et
surtout la profusion de décors
différents
keith est ce mélange que j'aime beaucoup
moins une menace tant les acteurs ici
c'est le rendre là c'est united' color
benetton et à aider les chinois mag h au
café noir métro à nous c'est très très
très très marrant et puis le petit piaf
c'est une histoire autour et pour le
petit soan
absolument au départ c'était pas lui
mais il avait écrit pour moi c'était pas
dans le haut des parcs scénario est
survenu donc j'ai travaillé on a vu le
petit sonne on dit ça c'est pour lui
quoi c'est un chanteur magnifique et
puis le film est très musical et en plus
on a repris la chanson de david sicard
mon pays vont faire une plusieurs
versions frmr duo avec marc lavoine
on avait envie d'une chanson que ça sur
la réunion qui se correspond à un peu
travailler c'est trop dur pour la
guadeloupe ou la martinique et donc il y
avait une voix physique et piles j'ai
passé et c'est cuit jouait super bien
la seule petite inconnue pour l'instant
c'est peut-être la date de sortie vous
avez une précision non ça c'est très
compliqué c'est vrai que là ça c'est le
vrai pour le
actuellement un film devait sortir à la
toussaint 2021
mais il ya une telle tellement de films
sur les étagères ça a passé peut-être à
noël mais comme il ya beaucoup de chine
pour la famille selon avions très
familial peut-être repartira sur février
pour les vacances de février mais tout
n'est renom viendra ici pour présenter
le film donc une avant première pour la
région
oui j'espère tiendra place que j'ai de
revenir
merci